hello everyone and welcome to another
interesting game but also a weird game
from the Hamburg Fida Grand Prix 2019
it's a battle of two yawns the young
shift of Duda versus Johnny polishing
and well best just dive straight into it
so without further ado yunxi to do that
opens the width c4d that's not a C C for
the English opening is on the board we
have E 5 Knight to c3 Knight to f6 in
the now g3 we have d5 so the reverse
dragon variation so to say C captures on
d5 Knight captures and Bishop to G to
now with a double attack on the night
here and if you don't want to trade you
have to retreat with the night so nice
to be six and Knight to f3 preparing to
Castle kingside
young goes Knight to c6 nipple we're not
gonna call anyone yawn in this matchup
so a3 and Bishop to e7 and b4 preparing
to develop the dark square bishop this
way castles by Neto and now III by Duda
and III is a new move in the position
there have been a few games where this
positioner was reached for castles was
played the b5 is a known move in the
position rook to be one is a known Moody
threesome but like I said III is uh is a
new move and it is as of move nine that
we have a completely new game so with a
six and now Queen to c2 just developing
the Queen preparing to castle and also
it's it's it's a good square for the
queen with Bishop to e6 and here nepo
finds a very nice idea he anticipates
the castle move because you don't want
to allow Bishop to c4 before castling
europe king will not be able to castle
so here we have castles
Bishop to c4 now attacking the rook
taking this tempo so an epic and play
Bishop to d3 so rook to d1 and Bishop to
d3 for the moment stifling White's
development so Queen to be 2 and now
Queen to d7 developing the Queen and
preparing to get the rooks into the game
but now you can't allow this Bishop to
stay here so Knights the e1 and the
bishop back to g6 so finally you can
pull the pawn you could decide to go for
d4 right away
do the decides it's best just play d3
and then maybe if in the future maybe
you'll need to play E for so you don't
want to over commit with d4 with rook a
to d8 buy nepo I bring in the rook into
the game and now Knight to e4 and this
is a well it's a very complicated
position Aleppo has a lot of ideas here
for example f5 is a very nice idea
Knights the c-4 is a very nice idea as
the rook on d1 is undefended so all of
these options are nice for example if
five this night is coming to c5 either
way so after captures captures and this
Knight gets attacked first you're gonna
play Bishop to h5 win a temple as this
rock is still undefended end after the
rook moves now you go Knight to d5 and
here it's it's a really tricky position
where black decides to well if white
wants to capture on b7 you you get to
push f4 and it well it will be a very
exciting game so f5 not a bad idea
Knight the c-4 also very tricky as it
comes with an attack on the Queen and
after the Queen moves again you first
win a temple by attacking this rook then
the chapter 3 is the best the ship
captures Knight captures and now Queen
to d5 with the idea that if captures
captures and captures you again lose the
rook on d1 so here the game the game
basically continues so those are one of
the two options nipple goes for the
third one which is Knight to d5 right
away so Duda goes for the c5 square
attack the Queen we have captures
captures and now the b7 pawn is under
attack so look to b8 and you can already
see that this variation isn't as
pleasant as the other two that we've
shown because now you oh you you already
developed the rook to d8 now you have to
bring it back to b8 at its it's not a
very active square but okay Queen to b3
now a double attack on the night is here
the bishop and queen are attacking it
rook F to da defending and now Bishop to
b2 finally developing this bishop with
night night back to f6 and then now rook
a to c1 bringing the other look into the
game as well and now Queen to e7 by
nipple so Queen to c3 and now comes the
bishop to h5 again stealing this tempo
as in the previous two variation
that we've shown look the d2 and here
efore sorry not by white efore by black
and this is a very interesting move by a
nipple here probably Napa has to go for
some light Knight to d5 but he played
efore and it seems like a very nice idea
but it's actually not so feel free to
pause the video and try to figure out
how to take advantage of this move well
I'll give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations as it appears to be a
pawn blunder or maybe not maybe nipple
just had some really really awesome idea
that is you know beyond our grasp but
you know whichever the case
congratulations to everyone who found it
it's Bishop captures on e4 for those of
you who just want to enjoy it show point
is that the bishop cannot be captured
point if pawn captures then after the
ropes are traded then okay Knight
captures black continues the game
everything is not everything is fine but
after E for do the played Bishop
captures on e4 and now it's just what
what was gained by this pawn push
because you cannot capture it due to
mate on g7 at the best friend Queen are
eyeing the g7 square so here nipple just
play the rook to d7 and it's it's really
a weird position so you sacrifice upon
the in flavor up to d7 but okay maybe he
just didn't want to a lot of whites
maybe to open up the default or
something like that but all in all it's
just well it's a weird move and now
Knepper wants the double up on the
default here but dude that doesn't allow
it
we have Bishop to f5 attacks the rook
rook to d5 and I'll just be for and here
if neppo nepo could go back to the 8th
but that's just admitting everything
you've played so far was bad so here he
decides to give up the exchange rook
captures an f5 we have pawn captures and
now rook to the 8th so here okay he's
now in the exchange he's down upon but
at least he has a light square bishop
and Duda does hips have some light
square weaknesses so maybe he can use
that to his advantage Queen the c-4 by
Duda and now Knight to d5 getting the
knight into the game and Queen to e4 now
Duda is now up mighty really wants to
trade Queens
Neph of course not interested Queen to
g5 and now F for pushing the Queen
further back Quinta h6 and now h3
preparing g4 to trap the bishop on h5
now we have F 6 by nipple creating a
square on f7 for his Bishop and the now
comes the night - g2 adding another
defender to the f4 pawn as both the
knight and the Queen are attacking yet
so preparing g4 we have rush up to f7 by
nipple and now just King to h2 night dte
7 getting the knight into the game and
now of g4 just not allowing this Queen
to enter the game ever again
Knight back to d5 as you don't really
have all that many squares you can use
to enter the game and now look the e2 we
have rook to e8 and here you could go
for captures captures can captures
probably you could play rook to e4 or
bring the other look over here and you
will still be better but there is no
there's no reason to do this you Rob
material you can just go Queen f3 which
is what to do that does rook captures
and now Queen captures Ani - and now g6
black now is trying to somehow get his
Queen back into the game also also
possible maybe instead of g6 you could
consider capturing on on f4 but then
Queen that III seems to post post some
problems I mean you don't really lose a
piece or anything you can just capture
on g2 and trade everything but you're
done material you're not interested in
making any trade so here g6 by Nippo F
captures we have h captures and now King
to g3 adding another defender to the f4
pawn also the King is much safer here
Knight the d8 preparing the Knights the
e6 but now Quinta efore just an eye
centralizing move with the Queen
we have c6 defending the knight here
well adding another defender to the
night and now again feel free to pause
the video and try to find the simplest
winning idea for white in this position
well I'll give you a couple of seconds
so for those who are able to do it
congratulations on finding such a nice
simple idea on how to take this game all
the way to a full point and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
Bishop captures on f6 this is what Duda
played it's a free pawn so why
grab it you could grab the bishop now or
maybe you don't want to if you don't
want it then you just lost another pawn
you're gonna move that bishop away put
the Queen on the dark squares and then
black is just helpless
so here neppo took now comes Queen to e7
with an attack on both nights and now
Napo decides to at least mess up White's
pawn structure while giving up giving
back the piece so G captures on h5 not
Knight 36 saving the other night but now
H captures an g6 and it was in this
position unmoved 44 that yani pony she
resigned the game and young Schuster
Duda takes the win in round one of the
Homburg fille de Grand Prix 2019 as
there is pretty well there's really
nothing to do here you are
even after capturing which check you are
now down two points in the exchange and
you don't have any control over the f4
pawn but just rook g1 threatening and
discoveries so after this is prevented
you can't really move the King go to the
H file so you have to play some like 97
now Ruby won the rook will capture the
b7 pawn push up the e6 you can threaten
the f3 pawn but then check King h7 check
now you again guard the pawn and I'll
just real capture some b7 and slowly but
surely you will win the game if Queen
captures on d3 you can even play a super
lame move like Queen g3 threatened mate
and hope for a queen trade because any
Queen trade is very favorable to you you
are still up two points and the exchange
so of course it's a completely winning
endgame so now after H captors on g6 I
do that takes the win in Game one and
we're gonna see what happens in Game two
two other games ended up with a with a
decisive result in round one Peter
Svidler defeated pantalla harikrishna
and also maxime beaugeois grab the feet
away e I didn't get to cover those games
I decided to show these two games as I I
thought these two were a bit more
exciting but maybe if we if well if I
get enough time I'm gonna show one of
those two as well so I would like to
thank parental LLC and the davits are
gone for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual
you can check - all my previous videos
here thank all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing the coverage of
the feeder Grand Prix continuing to
check up on your suggestions and still
preparing the next big saga so thank you
all I will see you soon and him an
excellent rest of your day